let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about r
which can be used for your visualization
now
one thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it
so the efficient way or effective way to
understand
what is in our data or what we have
understood
in our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand the data
and then you have explanatory
visualization
which helps us to share our
understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create
data visualizations and which can be
used for
both kind of data analysis or both kind
of visualizations
so when you talk about exploratory data
and visualization
the key is to keep all the potentially
relevant
details together now the objective when
we talk about
exploratory data analysis is to help you
see
what is in your data and the main
question
is how much details can we
interpret now when you talk about
different functions which we see here
such as plot which is more for a generic
plotting you have bar plot which is used
to plot
data using rectangular bars or you can
say creating bar
charts you have histogram or hist
function to create histograms where you
look at the
frequency of the data
are basically used to look at the
central tendency of the data
you have box plot which is used to
represent data in the form of
quartiles you have gg plot which is a
package which enables the user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plot lee or
plot ly it creates
interactive web-based graphs via the
open source javascript graphing library
now before we see some examples here
let's also talk about
when you talk about plotting let's also
try to understand
what kind of plots you can have
and what kind of techniques you have so
let me open up my r studio here
now for example i can pull out a
particular data set
and let's look at this one so
here i can look at all the panes
and that shows me the information now
what i can do is
i can install and get the
inbuilt data sets and then i can simply
do
a plot wherein i am doing a plot
on jquery data set so let's see what
does that show
it summarizes the relationship between
four variables in check
weight data frame which is in
ours built-in data set package now from
these plots we can see
for example weight varies systematically
over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets
now when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions
what features we would want to highlight
for emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated
right so there are different ways of
doing it now when you talk about your
graphics or visualizations you have
i would say three different types or you
can say four
so you have the base graphics which is
easiest to learn
now here we are having an example of
base graphics
where i can use the base graphics i can
get a
data set using library then i can simply
create
using plot function to a generate a
simple scatter plot of calories with
sugar from us serial data frame in the
mass package
and then i can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of base
graphics
now you also have what we call as grid
graphics which is powerful set of
modules for building other tools
now you also have latest graphics which
is
general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your gg plot
2 which
implements grammar of graphics and is
based on grid graphics so you have
different ways now here
since i already have used library and i
have the data set
i can just do a x so i can assign the
sugar related values to x and calories
related value to y
then i can use one more which is
library function and calling in grid now
i can
basically use functions such as push
view port
if i would want to create a plot using
your grid graphics
to create the similar kind of plot which
we created using base graphics but this
will
give you much more power than base
graphics
it will have a steep learning curve
but it is usually useful so i can
do this where i'm saying push view port
then i
can basically say i would want to have a
data viewport
i would say different functions of your
grid package
so i'm saying rectangle you have x-axis
y-axis given some points here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can basically create
a simple grid graphics based plot here
now there are different other options
which we can use to create plots
now before we go into understanding how
you create plots let me just give you a
brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used
so here we will look at these different
plots
now for example we have a bar
chart which is a graph which shows
comparisons
across discrete categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared
and y-axis which represents a measured
value
and height of the bars are proportional
to
measured values now to create
different kind of charts you can use
ggplot which is a package for creating
graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical sub units and that is a
part of tidy works ecosystem
so it takes each component of graph
accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects
and you can build graphs on particular
data
you can modify each of those components
in a way that's more flexible and user
friendly
you can if you are not providing details
for the components then ggplot will use
sensible defaults
and this basically makes it a powerful
and flexible tool
now here are different options when you
use your ggplot
such as you can use geom or what we call
as geometric objects
to form the basis of different type of
graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have scatter plots
that is underscore point you have
underscore box plot for box plots
you have quartile for continuous x
violin for richer display of
distribution and jitter
for small data so here is some simple
example
where i would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one
where we are using library function to
get the ggplot2 package
then basically we would want to look
into the mileage data
we would want to look at the structure
of it and then
we can basically get the tidy words
package
finally we can create a bar chart
using geo underscore bar and
we can basically also mention what would
be in x-axis
now you can also give different colors
to basically add more meaning to your
data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so here we are actually telling ggplot
to map the data in the drive column
to fill the aesthetic so here i am
giving
aesthetic access class and i'm saying
what is the data we need to have
and then we are using geom underscore
bar
so you can also have dodged bar
in your gg plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but
next to each other and you can create
that by using
your position as position underscore
dodge okay
now you can obviously use your different
packages which are inbuilt and you can
create your bar
charts and you have other kind of
graphs such as line graph which is
basically
a type of graph that displays
information as a series of data points
connected by straight line segments such
as this one and for this one we are
using
if you see jio underscore line now
you can also create a scatter plot which
is a two dimensional
data visualization that uses points
to graph the values of two different
variables one in
an x axis one on y axis like what we saw
in base graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship
or lack of relationship between two
variables
and you also have histogram which i
mentioned
is mainly to look at the distribution of
a data to look at the central tendency
of the data
basically looking at your
large amount of data or for a single
variable you would be
interested in saying where is more
data found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its
mid point or what we call as mean median
mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins
so these are some basics on different
kind of graphs now we can look at some
examples
and see how that works so what we were
seeing is
some quick examples of base graphics or
grid graphics now here
let's do an example of pie chart for
different products and units sold
so you want to create a graph for this
first let's create a vector and pass in
the value here
now i can also create labels which i
would want to assign to these values
and then basically i can plot the chart
by saying
pi so that's the kind of chart which i
would want to create
and i would say the data would be x and
labels so let's do this and that shows
me a simple pie chart
now i can also give main details here so
instead of just doing a pi
x comma labels i can say what is the
main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow
so this is the way you can create a
simple
plot now i can also find out what is the
percentage
and then basically i would be
interested in plotting the pie chart
which takes
x which takes the labels which will be
the percentage which we are calculating
here by doing a round
function and then you can basically give
details to your
graph you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be
in your chart what are the values
and then basically fill up the colors so
let's run this one
and that shows me the percentage which
was calculated
and it gives me the details and we can
always have a look at our plot now
if you would want to go for a 3d pie
chart
then you can get the package which is
plotrix let's use that by calling in the
library function
let's pass in some data to x and let's
give some values or labels which will
make more meaning to the data and then
let's plot the
3d graph so i'm saying pi 3d here
where i'm using x and labels then i'm
basically
doing an explode which will basically
control how your graph looks like
and basically give the values so it also
takes the title
when you say main and by chart of
countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we are
create using the c function creating a
vector
and then let's create a histogram for
this one
where i would say x lab what would be
your
data around x-axis what is the color
what is the border
and here i am creating a simple
histogram
which as i discussed earlier will always
show
your values on the x-axis and y-axis
is more of frequency and then you can
look at
the set of values and what is their
frequency
and we can basically use this histogram
for
exploratory data analysis look at the
data try to understand what is the
central tendency of your data values
now we can also give some limits by
using the
x limb and y limb and then i can
also specify what is the limit so we
have given some values here
wherein we have said your x limit is 0
to
40 and y limit is 0 to 5.
now if you compare this with the
previous one which we had created
this one based on the frequency had
taken the limits
but we can assign limits explicitly by
giving this
and then create a histogram which makes
more meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality
let's view this to see what does that
data contain so you have
ozone solar wind temperature month and
the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot
where as i mentioned you would be
interested in analyzing
variables and see what is the
relationship between them
so to plot a graph between ozone and
wind values
so we will say plot we will say the data
which is
air quality from that i would be
interested in the ozone column
or ozone field and the wind field i can
create a plot based on this
now i can also be saying what should be
the color
what is the type of the data which you
would want to create
and you can look at the info information
so you can create a histogram you can
create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data
better and then infer some information
from that data
so let's take the air quality data set
itself
without specifying any particular column
and you can create a plot which shows me
all the different values which you have
in the data
and it basically shows you the
difference this is
more of an example like what we did for
chickweight where we
did a base graphics now you can assign
labels to the plot
so that is when you are creating a plot
you can say air quality
you will say ozone and then that's your
ozone concentration you have your
y lab which is the number of instances
you have what is the title ozone levels
in new york city what is the color
so these are the details what we have
given with our plot function
and let's look at the data so it just
tells me
that this is the ozone concentration
the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data
now we could also create a histogram by
picking up a particular column
that is such as solar from your air
quality
and that basically shows me the
frequency of
solar values and we can then try to find
out what is the mid
what is the mean what is the standard
deviation
and so on you can also look at your
histogram and try to understand
if it is left skewed and right skewed so
we can do that
now here let's get the temperature out
from this particular data set
let's create a histogram on temperature
and that basically shows me the
frequency
of the temperature values and
what values have the most frequency or
most occurrence
now you can create a histogram with
labels so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which
also takes the values and for each
set of frequency or each set of values
it gives me the labels
now you can have a histogram with
non-uniform width
so you could do that by doing a hist
function
and then passing in your temperature
you can say what will be the main what
is the title
what will be your x lab it will tell you
a limit
around x axis what is the color what is
the border
what are the breaks you would want to
have for your bars
and you can simply create a histogram
using this
so this basically takes the breaks which
we have given
such as 55 to 60 60 to
70 70 to 75 and so on so this is
basically creating a histogram with
non-uniform width and it purely depends
on the kind of values what you have
now you can also create a box plot which
sometimes helps us in understanding the
the data quartiles also understanding
our
outliers so you can create multiple box
plots
based on the data from air quality so
we'll select all the data
and then we'll do some slicing on the
data so let's create a box plot which
tells me
the values and if you look at these
points here
like single dots these are basically
your outliers
we can learn about that more in later
sections
so you can use your gg plot
2 library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install dot packages and get
ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart r and
i can say yes
so let it get the package i think the
package was already there
and now let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that i have the
library function
and let's do a attach where i'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then i will create a variable p1
i will use ggplot i will pass in my data
i'll give the aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot
to basically create a plot which gives
me
the box plot for the values here and
this is based on
the cylinders which is there in your
data so we can always look at what does
our data contain
and what kind of values or features
are available in the data now let's
create a box plot
we will also use the coordinate function
and that basically gives me
based on the data so i've changed the
coordinates
now if you look at the previous one
where we created a plot
we had mileage on the y-axis and
cylinders
on the x-axis now i did a coordinate
flip
and that's like your transpose function
so you have created the box plot but you
have just flipped the coordinates
you can create a box plot and then say
fill which is the factor of cylinder
so that can be used to fill up the
values in your box plot
now what we can also do is we can
create factors so we have learnt about
factors earlier
which is usually used to work on
categorical variables
so here let's create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am
you have cylinder and if you look at
the factors which we have created we
have passed our data
what is the field or the column we are
interested in what is the level
of values there and what are the labels
for those values
right so we have learnt about factors
you can always look into the previous
section
and learn more about factors now let's
create
a scatter plot by using the ggplot
function
again we will use the data as empty cars
i will go for
mapping option and then i will give my
aesthetics
that is what would be x what would be
your y
and you also would want to use what kind
of
function you are using so let's go for
geom pawn
point and that basically helps me in
creating a scatter plot
now you can create a scatter plot by
factors
so here we will say gg plot
so notice in all of these cases
depending on the kind of data you have
depending on the kind of plot you are
interested in you will use the
gg plot and then basically a function
with that
or the inbuilt package so here i'm
saying data is empty cars
i am going for mapping which basically
will take the values for your
x and y what is the color and the
coloring will be done based on the
factor values
now if you remember factors will
obviously have some levels
and those levels will basically help you
in differentiating between your
categorical variables
so i am saying as dot factor on cylinder
and then
i'm using geom point to basically create
this scatter plot so let's do this
and i can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
which says must at least one color from
the
hue palette so let's look at that one
so the error which we were facing when
we gave color
as the factor values was because when
you look at these factors which were
created
with some labels if we look at the
values of these it tells me there are
any values in that particular column
similarly your gear
or similarly you can completely look at
the complete data set
it tells me cylinder you have am you
have care
now these have some we have created some
labels but these have
n a values so what we can do is we can
create a scatter plot
as we did earlier by giving the
aesthetics and that's a simple
scatter plot wherein i'm also using geom
point
so that i can have these points by
defaults or with defaults
you can also give a color specific
basically if you would want to have
different kind of data in the same plot
or i can create scatter plots
by different sizes by giving a size or
i can give a color and size and that's
again
one way in which you can create your
scatter plots now
let's also see how you can visualize
one more data set which is mpg
so i can also do it in this way where i
set ggplot2
and then pass and look at the data set
what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the fields have
any any values
if that's going to affect your plotting
so now
what we can do is we can create a bar
plot or a bar
chart so i am saying gg plot the data
would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot2
mpg then i will say what should be in my
aesthetics
and what kind of chart are you going to
create so i'm saying geom underscore bar
so that's my bar chart and that has
basically your class and count
now you can create a stacked bar chart
where your information is stacked
in the same bars and we are still using
the same data
we are going for aesthetics which is
class
and then when you say geom bar which
creates your stack bar
we will use fill which is drive
and we can always go back and look at
our
data for example you can always look
into this so you have the drive column
here
and you are also working on this
complete data set
so let's go ahead and create a stacked
bar chart
and that basically gives me the
information where you have
the drive information which is stacked
here
now you can do a dodge by giving the
position as dodge
so we are still going to go for a stack
chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful
you can use this by using geom point
where you are mapping
and you are specifying what are your
aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class
and we have different classes and based
on that
my points have been colored now you can
also use a plot
ly or plotly library so let's install
this one i will say yes for example
let it basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then i can access that package using
library function
and then create a variable to which you
are assigning your plot underscore ly
plot so data is empty cars what will be
your x-axis what will be your y-axis
and details on your marker which we have
given
wherein i will give a list which is size
color which is a combination and then
you have your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where
i am going to use plot ly
and let's look at this plot so
it basically gives me some information
now we see some warnings which are
getting generated
but there is you don't need to worry
about that
so you can look at the packages what you
have and
what options you are using so similarly
we can create one more plot
using plot ly and look at the values of
those
so that's a plot with a trend which
explains me about
my data so this is a simple small
tutorial on understanding or
how you can have your graphics or
visualization
used to understand your data obviously
there are much more examples
much more ways in which you can pass
into your plot functions
or your gg plot and the inbuilt
packages which are available in r for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or explanatory
data analysis
so try these graphs and see if
you can change these options and try or
create new visualizations
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here